هذا رائع جدًا إنه مفيد أيضًا بشكل لا
يصدق بالنسبة لك عندما علمت لأول مرة
أنك ستكون قادرًا على دراسة
هذا
ما كان رد فعلك
جيدًا أنا مهووس به أيضًا لأن
هذه مجرد أحفورة
رائعة وأتذكر أنها كانت من قبل
بدأ الوباء ، تلقيت بعض
الصور من زملائي في الصين
، وعندما فتحت هذه الصور ، شعرت
بالصدمة لأن هذا ديناصور صغير
داخل بيضته وهو
يستعد للفقس وقد تم التقاطه في
الحجر مثل هذه الحفرية  وليس
لدينا أي أحافير أخرى مثل هذه تمامًا ،
لذا بالنسبة لي ،
هذا يشبه تمامًا
صورة الموجات فوق الصوتية التي قد تكون لدينا
لطفل بشري ، هناك هذه الحفريات التي
تظهر لنا هذا الديناصور الصغير وهو
يستعد للتو للظهور في
العالم يجب أن أقول ii أجد الصور
ساحرة لأنها في حالة ممتازة
لديك جنين الديناصورات هذا
ويمكنك رؤية الهيكل العظمي الهش الصغير
هناك تمامًا ما تعلمته من
رؤية  في مثل هذه التفاصيل ،
فإن التفاصيل لا تصدق وعندما
تفكر فقط في احتمالات
وجود أحفورة لديناصور صغير داخل
بيضتها ، فإن هذه البيضة يبلغ طولها حوالي ست سبع بوصات ،
فهذا شيء صغير حساس
ويتم الحفاظ عليه لمدة 70 مليون
سنة  مذهل
وليس فقط هذا واحد من بين مليار
أحفورة ، إنه في الواقع أحفورة مهمة للغاية
لأنه يخبرنا الكثير عن
كيفية استنساخ الديناصورات كيف
طوروا كيفية
نموهم وعندما تنظر إلى هذه الصور هذا
العمل الفني الرائع الذي قام به زملائي في
الصين و  لقد جمعت كندا معًا أعتقد
أنه من المقبول جدًا أن يكون هذا
ديناصور صغير داخل بيضته يشبه إلى
حد كبير طائرًا ، وإذا رمشت عينك ،
فقد تعتقد أن هذا كان دجاجة أو
عصفورًا وهذا لأنه يمتلك
نفس الموقف بالضبط في  البيضة يكون
رأسها ملتويًا تحت ذراعيها
وهو نفس الوضع الذي تتخذه الطيور في
بيضها وهذا كله يتعلق بطائر
أو في هذه الحالة ديناصور
يستعد للنمو ، لذا  ead في
الوضع الصحيح لاختراق البيضة حتى
تتمكن من الفقس الناجح